[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm christopher hein
we're going to talk a little bit about
how
the goals that i outlined are actually
going to help us achieve the philosophy
of
aikido so how those goals are related to
aikido um aikido philosophy so our main
three goals
are the ability to be ahead of someone
the ability to maintain distance from
someone and the ability to position
uh well to someone right so to have a
good position so those are each
goals and those goals can each be used
as a tactic
now why they're goals so understand that
in our aikido philosophy
we're dealing with a martial art that
has something roughly to do with
um not hurting someone else right so
that's something that's espoused a lot
in aikido philosophy is that aikido is
not about hurting someone else right
something that allows us to defend
ourselves right so meaning that
not only do i not want to hurt someone
else but i have to deal with someone
else who does
probably want to hurt me so how are we
going to manage that right
and then something that enables me to
use their desire to attack against them
and not have to have a lot of force and
power myself right so this is another
big thing in aikido is
that you know a smaller guy is able to
deal with a bigger guy or a stronger guy
or more
more forceful attacks right and this is
something that a lot of different
martial arts systems talk about is that
littler people can deal with bigger
people
but i think aikido does it in a little
bit more of a
general way in a more specific way at
the same time right so let's talk about
those goals and how those goals help us
achieve that
so if i am ahead of someone if i'm
mentally ahead of someone
then i don't have to take drastic
actions to
take care of myself right so meaning if
i know if i go over there
that guy is going to go nuts and he's a
big strong dude and he's gonna attack me
and
and the only way i could defend myself
would be to shoot him or or stab him or
do something terrible that's the only
way if i got
in a situation with that guy if i am
mentally ahead like that then i can just
choose
not to go there right so that helps me
achieve
all of my aikido philosophy right so if
i don't go over there and that guy
doesn't attack me then
i don't hurt him he doesn't hurt me and
essentially he doesn't even have an
attack to use against him
so i could be the smallest guy in the
world and that will work right so
i don't have to have a lot of power in
order to enact that i just have to be
aware of what's going on way in advance
now there are times when you're going to
have to go
into a place where there's potential
danger so you're not always able to
avoid potentially dangerous spots so
mental headedness can go further into
that right so
you know i know i'm going into a
dangerous spot but i want to do it in a
way that makes me
not obvious to anyone who would want to
attack me or seem friendly to people who
would want to attack me
or have people with me who would help me
in bad situations
or go into it in a defended way so if
someone did attack me it wouldn't turn
out very good for them
so there's again an example of a mental
headedness i've prepared right we call
this preparation
i've prepared for what's going to happen
over there what could potentially happen
over there
so i'm a little bit ahead of the
situation and then that that
headedness falls all the way down to
what in martial arts is called
senseno sin means to be
in the moment before the moment of
attack right so and that is essentially
if i was uh talking to someone and i can
tell they're going to hit me in
one second right and i'm able to act in
that moment before they're able to act
and that's the the last headedness that
we have in aikido
and in fact when asked about the timings
of
martial arts right which are go no sin
to be after the moment
send sin to be in the moment and sin and
no sin to be
before the moment yoshiba said aikido is
none of those things right aikido is not
any of those because aikido is more than
that there's
something else going on and that in fact
aikido victory doesn't happen
in moments it happens instantly it's
already ahead in aikido and i think he's
alluding to this
being a headedness and so the last
aheadness we could have in aikido
would be sensing no sin but but it's
actually in in our philosophy
kind of still far behind right so ahead
over all of what's going
on but for iketer not the best and so
that's one of our main goals is to be
ahead
and you can see how being a head allows
us to ideally not have to hurt the other
person
not get hurt ourselves and not need an
amazing amount of physical force
okay now if we can't manage any of those
and there's going to be times where you
can't get any of those to happen right
you get surprised and all kinds of bad
stuff happen
the next major goal we have is
distancing
now distancing again fits in perfectly
with our philosophy
if i'm really far away from someone well
then it's going to be really hard for
them to attack me right so
even if they have projectile weapons it
gets harder and harder the further they
get away
right so even a really skilled sniper
with a scope and this would be a
a crazy situation but even a really
skilled sniper with the scope the
further away i get from that guy
the harder it's going to be for him to
get me right so certainly someone
without a projectile weapon
the further away i am the safer i am so
um if i can manage to keep a distance
uh they i won't have to hurt them um
they won't be able to hurt me
and i don't need a lot of physical force
right so in fact i need no physical
force really at a distance
now as i keep the distance i might need
to be able to move and all kinds of
stuff like that
and so there is some physicality that
might come into play but if i can
achieve
distancing then i don't have to worry
about anything else i'm achieving my
aikido philosophy right so i'm doing all
the aikido philosophical stuff we talked
about
and i can use if if i'm mentally ahead i
can use that to always keep my distance
and if i get mentally behind i can use
distance to reset my mental headedness
right so so meaning if
there's potentially someone who could
surprise me if i always stay away from
them they can't surprise me
too quickly right so meaning if i keep
at least our basic ma i which is this
arm reach distance they probably can't
hit me before i can have some kind of
reaction to it
and then if i can create more distance i
can then start to mentally get ahead of
them right which is what i want so
so the distancing is a goal that totally
in and of itself
lets me achieve my aikido philosophy and
also can be used as a tactic
to help me get ahead again which is
another one of my big goals for aikido
philosophy
now the last of these is superior
positioning
now again if i have a really really
great position and a great position
could be anything like
you know hiding so no one even knows i'm
there that's a great position
or it could be that i'm on top of a
mountain and it'd be a lot of work to
get up to me or i'm in a safe room or
all kinds of things
or it could be as simple as just being
behind someone and that's our ideal
simple position in aikido which is the
eating me position to be behind someone
now if i can achieve really good
position again i can keep them
from hurting me while i don't have to
hurt them
and at the same time it doesn't require
a lot of physical force so you see how
again this goal
beautifully lines up with what my aikido
philosophy is
and that goal can be used as a tactic
to help me with my other ones so let's
say i let the distance get
all messy and i certainly wasn't ahead
of them if i can get myself to the
to the ideal position the eating me
position behind them then it's going to
be easier for me to distance easier for
me to
make them to dictate to them what they
have to do right so they have to come
around me in some way to get to me
so positioning can help me reset to my
other two goals as well so
positioning can be used as a tactic and
in of itself it is
one of the goals of my aikido philosophy
right and so we're saying the rough
aikido philosophy is
you know i don't want to hurt anyone uh
while they're not
able to hurt me and i want to not have
to use a lot of physical force to do it
so
if i'm able to keep um all of my
interactions in that
high level tactical situation right
which is where i'm always juggling
distance a headedness and position then
i won't ever have to deal with physical
situations with someone nothing too
terribly physical
i won't ever have to hurt anyone at
those distances
and it would be very very difficult for
them to hurt me so those three main
goals which are also
tactics are what's enabling me to
actually achieve my aikido philosophy
so we're going to go down from here uh
we'll talk a little bit more about
tactics and we'll get down and we'll
talk about uh techniques as well and a
lot of people are familiar with
techniques we'll talk about how the ikea
techniques are actually really good for
what we do
i'm christopher hine thanks a lot for
watching